In Season 1, you saw that we found a small
water reservoir right next to Basekamp.
We cleared around it.
And, we went in to explore this delicious water.
But, we got busy with a lot of otherstuff
and somehow forgot about it.
So, now, two years later,
we're going to give it a bigmakeover.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
Hey! So, here we are next to our lake/pond/
water reservoir...
I don't know how you call this...
We cleaned this up in the beginning,
when we cameto this land actually, but left it ever since...
In the beginning, there was a lot of water,
but nowit's the middle of summer, so it almost dried up.
But, there's still some water...
So, currently, it's quitea good time to rework it.
Because, then we can do it before
the winter season starts and all therain gets in.
And it also becomes more and more useful
to have this reservoir around...
Because, as you cansee from above,
here's Basekamp and here's the reservoir.
It's currently a bit overgrownaround mimosas,
but it's quite useful to have a big chunk of water here.
In case of a fire, or justto cool down.
So, before we're going to work on it,
let me show you what it actually looks like.
And, I'mgoing to show you first person, so you can really see
why we want to rework this thing with a GoPro.
All right! So, first up:
This is what it looks like from here...
And, as you can see, a lotof vegetation started to grow back
around the edges, which could be cleaned up.
Secondly, as you can see here, it start to really erode.
So, the whole area, the wall is super steep,
and itwas really dug out.
Which, every now and then it just collapses like here.
So, slowly the wholewall eroded.
Also there, the only thing really that keeps it up
is all the mimosa trees right there.
The roots maintain a little bit of the structure.
And, the whole wall is really just like crumblingapart.
These roots still give some strength to it.
It's very delicious water...
And it's still pretty deep, I think, inthe middle.
And, here in the back, there's still a lot of
old, dead trees from the fire.
As you cansee, they burned down.
But, this height difference is really big,
so here's a big road on top and slowlythis erodes more as well.
So, we want to clean it up.
The reason why it looks like thisis that the
previous owner saw some water here.
And, he just dug it out, so there wasmore water available.
That's why the walls are so steep.
And, they also saythere used to be a pipe from here to the bottom of the land.
We've never seen it, but the neighbors keep talking about it.
To distribute the water across the land,
so maybe we'll find that when working on it.
It becomes a bit swampy.
And, the water level, as you can see, is now here.
But, originally, it's there like right under where all the rootstart,
which is more in the winter time.
So it would be here. So it's quite a big difference that it fills up in the winter.
And also, Mattia dropped in the first year when we came here,
and we started cleaning these up, pliers here or scissors.
- Yeah, my phone just dropped in there.
No, the scissors just dropped in there...
- Fuck!
So, maybe we're going to find that back as well,
I hope so!
I'm curious to see what it looks like.
But, let me show you the coolest part,
which we can see righthere now.
Because, it's summer and the water level is low.
But, this used to be a natural spring!
So, here, it's very moist, because somewhere
in this area was a natural spring.
Which makes sure the water just flows here.
You can see little bits of it!
So, I'm not sure if you can see it, but here you can see the water coming back.
Even though the water level is higher than there.
So, this is where the spring used to be around here.
But, I'm not sure if it's still active, and how much it gives...
So, themoment we start digging, I guess we're going to see better.
The plan: we're first going to cleanup a little bit around it.
And, take some dead trees out
Also, there's a lot of stuff laying around.
Then, we're going to pump the lagoon empty,
so we can see how deep it actually is.
To seeif we find some other things there, and also...
To see if the the spring renews itself,
and what the water table level actually is.
And then, with a digger,
we're going to clean upthese eroded edges.
We'll put them under angle,
so it doesn't collapse anymore when the watergets in.
And then, we also start cleaning up in that area,
where we find a lot of mimosas.
We're going to keep the mimosas for the roots.
But, in between, there's a lot of firewood,
which is a lot of dead wood, which is a fire hazard...
So, we're going to clean that up aswell.
Hopefully, in the end, there's going to be a nice area here.
But, let's see!
I've never done thisbefore.
We start by pulling out some brambles and spiky bushes.
So, the front part is now cleanenough.
Now, we need to go to the back,
but let me bring you closer, so you can see what it looks like.
Because, it's a bit more rough!
So, the back part here -- we never cleaned it up before...
So, there'sstill a lot of old dead trees.
And it's very steep and eroding,
so it's going to be a bit harder to cleanthis up.
But, I guess we're just going to go for it!
So, it's now all cleaned up.
As you might have seen,it's pretty steep and everything crumbles down.
But, there are a few natural things that happen toprevent this.
Let me show you!
So, what happens is that every now and then,
a stick falls sideways, like here or there.
And, it gets stuck between thetrees, so it cannot slide down.
And then, allthe little smaller sticks and branches,
they're getting stuck between there, which creates abit of a terrace...
Also a little bit of a stairs.
And, this is useful, because it prevents everything sliding down.
So, you have a bit of a shield.
It also retains some water, which is good!
And, in the end, the main thing is just that
not the whole lake gets full of sticks...
Now, there actually are little sticks, which I just took out.
We're going to use the big ones toreally build
more of these enforcements between the trees.
So, we create a bunch of terraces thatwe can walk up,
and to have this whole area a bit stronger.
So, that's going to be the principle.
Now, we are just going to put more up.
So, next, you need to make some space
so wehave the water here...
Then, there's some sort of a pathway here and mimosas there.
But, thedigger needs to come in order to make
this wall less steep, so we need more space here.
So,we're going to chop some of the mimosa trees.
The trees are right there and we're going
to use a chainsaw, because it's quite a lot of them.
So, everything is now chopped!
Now comesthe fun part: moving it...
We got Jaime helping out for that.
All right, so, it's cleaned up here.
All thethe trees are chopped here.
Now, next, we need to empty this water leftover that is in there
to see what's actually down.
To see how deep it is, and maybe we find that plier,
or the pipe thatthe neighbors say is there...
Or, maybe we even find a suitcase of gold!
It could easily be the case.
Let's see, and pump it up!
So, here we have a water pump.
It has two hoses -- one where thewater goes in, and one out.
The downside is the incoming hose is not super long...
That'sjust the one we had.
And, I made a filter from an old little jerrican with some holes
tomake sure all the dirt and stuff doesn't go in the pump...
So, ideally now, we just put it inthere
and let it run till it's empty.
Let's see!
As we were pumping the water, we ran intosome problems...
The engine of the pump stopped all the time.
And, if it was running, it actually didn'treally suck anymore.
We tried a bunch of things, but we're not sure what's going on.
We're still new to theworld of water pumps.
So, we asked an old expert for help...
Our neighbor Antonio, and his50-year-old water pump.
Look at that beast!
And, he has his own filter system.
An improvisation guy just like us.
So, to get going, we connected the tube on the bottom,
then the top, do a little magical thing with the engine...
Wind up the old rope.
Get some grip on that kitchen knife
and do one good pull!
Very smooth.
So, water iscoming out, but it could be more!
So, we need to do some wiggling.
And, meanwhile, the pump is going strong.
Yeah sure, some leaks, but the lid is popping
and the knife is dancing.
And, the water is flowing.
So, now, we just have to wait for the water to go.
The last part was pretty hard toempty up.
While reaching the bottom,
it got very muddy and stuff started to appear...
I see something there!
And, it also got very smelly...
Lookat all the gas bubbles around my feet
popping up when walking around!
Ok, butnow, it's empty enough for the next step:
The digger.
The first step for the diggeris to take out
all the dirt that is in there.
Some of it is trash, but mostly it'sfallen sticks,
burned trees and some some leaves.
While digging, wesaw a lot of frogs jumping away.
Especially in the front part.
So, the frog team jumped in to rescue.
- It's going to jump out!
We don't really know if it's an experiment,
but we saw all these frogs!
Theywere going with near the tractor, and we thought:
''Okay, let's try to get someto recreate the biodiversity.''
In the bucket, we have many, many things to be accounted for.
We have like 10 of these!
- Where's the frogs?
We have frogs, but they are a bit shy.
- Let's see...
So, thatwas basically a day of digging.
Most of the dirt is out!
Especially the last shallow part had alot of laying around.
The solid and organic stuff that came out
was put here on the side.
It was surprisingly grey compared to the rest of the soil around.
Well, let me show you whatit looks like!
So, the lake is now dug out.
All the dirt is out, and it's quite a lot deeperthan we thought!
Yeah, which is cool!
It can hold a lot of water and we also found a fewthings.
So, I think we found the pipe that
the neighbors always talk about.
It goes tothe big ruin, the Community Center,
on the bottom of the land.
There used to be thispipe,
so the water from here can be used there.
We think it's this pipe, but we're not reallysure...
Because, we also found another pipe, which is a bit smaller.
A slightly different position.
We're notsure of what water goes in or out....
it's kind of a mystery.
I don't know how you would everfind out where these pipes go...
So, if you have any suggestions, let us know!
And, it's now alsopretty clear to see
where the spring is, or where the water is flowing.
Because, its now all empty.
Here, you see a little bit of water sipping through.
And, it's really the highest point.
You can see all the water going down here.
now it's accumulating there at the
back.
And, he actually dug a nice hole,
so now we can put the water pump there.
Because, currently, we're having a break.
The guy is having some lunch.
So, we can put the pump there to makesure
it doesn't fill up too much when he comes back...
And, we're going to work on the edges
tomake sure they're less steep.
The scissors fell somewhere here,
but I don't think we'regoing to find it...
And, if we're going to find it, it's now on the top.
So, maybe later, when we'll just
walk around on the land we would find it.
- Clean shoes, eh Dave?
Yeah, it looks a bit like a battlefieldat this point.
And, from above, it actually looks like a big cow poop.
Next,it was time to reduce the steepness
on the sides to reduce the inclination.
And,  this was quite satisfying to watch.
Next, the guy with the digger still came back
to do some fine tuning workwith a smaller digger.
We didn't film much of this,
because it didn'tseem very interesting.
Until, he found this...
It was the scissors Mattia dropped in the water!
So, after what...?
2 years in here?
We found it back when he was digging he found our old wrench.
Wrench?Clippers?
I don't know what you call this.
It's a bit rusty...
I got pretty curious of thecondition of it now,
and see if it still works.
So, here we are at the workspace,
tryingto see if we can fix this one up.
All the parts are replaceable, so it should be possible.
And, some parts are still in good condition!
But, let's see if we can clean it up.
So, thealuminum handle with the rubber is still very good!
Only the real metal parts hereare rusty.
I'm not sure if we can just clean
the rust away and it would still work...
And, possibly -- this is the blade that cuts...
I'm not sure if we can still manage to sharpen that one.
And, the spring here is missing as well...
So, here's the blade, but it's stilla little bit rough and dull...
I found a replacement kit which has a blade
and this thing.
This thing, we need it anyway.
But, for the blade, I guess I'm trying to going
to see if I can actually sharpen this one.
Before we're going to need a new one...
So,then we can keep this for another point in time.
And, for that, we just goingto give it a try with a sharpening stone.
All right, so, the blade is cleaned up and sharpened again on the edge.
So, now,it's time for the fun part, which is assembling.
So, here we are!
It seemsto work good, but let's give it a test.
So, that was pretty cool.
I did not expect it wouldstill work that well!
So, now, the team can use it for their
next cleaning job to cut bushes.
Whichis actually right now!
- So, as you can see Dave and the digger
already did their job here on thisside.
Now, it's time for General Help team to work on that side.
It's a mess, full of very dry, dead and thinmimosas.
So, we're mainly going to remove the thinner ones.
The thick ones are the ones we leaveto give some shade
and also to hold the soil a bit.
Also, we have to avoid this from
happening while we're working here.
One of the priorities is to make surethat
all of the debris doesn't go back into the pond...
- And, that we also don't gointo the pond...
We also don't go into the pond.
Barbed wire, our lovely friend,got stuck on the chainsaw.
Hopefully, nothing major, but it's pretty annoying...
It'sannoying for the people, and annoying for the machines.
- Nice!
Okay, one less...
Now, this whole area has a cleared path.
So, we have easier access to the pond.
Not only does it look much nicer, and easier towork around...
It also prevents most of the soil for going into the water.
You can see that this looks waybetter.
Much more light!
We have a lovely path to access the whole area.
All of this stuff thatwe cut down is now on the floor.
It looks a bit messy but it's the best for the soil.
ClassicGeneral help stuff!
Now, it's time for Dave to keep the the rest of the project.
- Good luck Dave!
So, next, I'm going to dig an overflow.
So, if the winter the water level goes up.
To makesure it doesn't go over all the edges,
but it has a specific place where it can flowout.
So, I'm going to dig it right there!
I'm just going to dig a gutter, just so  that it can goout.
I'm not going to put in a pipe yet and cover it back up.
Because, I'm not sure yet whatwill be
the appropriate height to put it in.
So, I'm just going to dig it for now
and thenobserve this winter to see how this whole thing behaves.
I can see what you're thinking!
That couldhave been done with a digger, a bit faster.
I agree...
Alright, so, the overflow ready!
Now, we'rewaiting for rain to come in the winter,
and see how it's going to behave.
I'm kind ofcurious how high the water level would get!
And finally, we leveled the soila bit more
and added a seed mix that would provide a ground cover.
To make sureit doesn't really erode
and everything sticks together better.
Which should behappening, when it all starts growing later on.
All right, so, it's ready! Let me show you theend!
So, here we have the lake/swamp/lagoon?
Let me know how I should call this!
But, we clearedit up and now it's much deeper.
We can hold much more water, which is cool!
So, there's already somewater in here.
Some frogs are coming back, which is cool!
But, the main bulk amount of water
would come in winter, when it would start to rain.
And, hopefully, to fill up this thing.
So, here,we have the overflow, and the water level is there.
We still need to fill up all theway here.
And, when the water level reaches this point, it flows out there.
To make sure it doesn't breakall the other walls.
So, at the moment the soil is still very crumbly,
We added this layeron top with a seed mix
to provide a ground cover.
To protect the soil, but also hopefully compact it
and compress it a bit together.
Just so it all stays in shape properly.
We cleaned up this side, so,
now we can access it properly.
But, this whole wall is still the same as before...
We're not surewhat we're going to do with it yet.
And, the plan is first to just see how
this all behaves, what wejust did now.
And, in the winter after it fills up,
and maybe next year in the summer when it's dryagain...
We can see if we want to rework this wall.
But, for now, at least we can access it properly,
and observe how it behaves.
So, that was it for now!
A pretty big difference before and after!
It still looks a bit bare and raw, but it will get better as
the top cover grows and new treesare planted.
The main upside is that we now have
a bigger water reservoir close to Basekamp.
Which will be good in the dry summer months.
So, we will continue to observe and work on thisplace.
It will be nice when the first rain comes,
to see how this whole evolves.
And, we willmake sure to post some pictures
on Patreon in the winter on how the process is evolving.
So,if you want to see that make sure
to support us, so you can see them!
Or not, and then you just seeit in a video update at some point.
Anyway, that was it!
Thank you for watching and see you nexttime!
In the next update, we will work on another water area on the land.
We'll be doing some maintenance around the waterfall.
And, we will also continue building our house from the pig trailer.
Thanksfor watching, and see you in the next update!